[موسيقى]
الاعتراف بان هذه المراه لها دور ولها راي
وانها تدعم يكون لها
معرض يكون لاعب مشاركات يكون لها تقدير
كلها قيمه فنيه
في المجتمع
يبتدوني يركزون عليها هذا
[موسيقى]
انا عشت في عيله فنيه فكنت من الصغر من
ناحيه ماما اشوف الالوان
والفرش والمساحات هذه اللي الواحد
مشاعرك كلها تطلع معاها ومن ناحيه البابا
كان الهندسه شويه يعني اشوف خطوط الهندسيه
فمن الصغر كنا عايشين بهالجوف والحمد لله
يعني اكتشفت نفسي اني انا اعرف ارسم واحب
الرسم بس يعني
اشكر مدرستي في المرحله الابتدائيه سنه
ثاني ابتدائي
اعطتني كلمه خليتها في دماغي يعني انت
لازم تدرسين فنون انت شغلك حلو وانت
ترسمين حلو وانت افكار حلوه كنت صغيره
استوعب الكلام هذا بس ظل في بالي
[موسيقى]
كنت بالبدايه كنت
وايد استخدم اللون الاحمر في شغلي على
اساس يكون مثل حق المتلقي انه اللون
الاحمر يلفت نظره للشغل
فبديت اثبت حالي انه لا احنا
كفنانات تشكيلات في عندنا فكره في عندنا
موضوع نشتغل عليه في عندنا ثقافه في عندنا
رؤيه في عندنا امكانيات نسخرها ترجمه هذه
الافكار على هذا اللوح
فبديت اثبت نفسي
معرض ورا معرض ورا معرض فالحمد لله قدرت
يعني اخذ مساحه
بالمشهد التشكيلي الكويتي
[موسيقى]
الفطر الحاليه قاعده اشتغل على
ضياع الهويه عندنا
اتمنى اني اوصل باعمال لاني اوصلها لاكبر
عدد من الدول والمشاركات
لان الهويه فقط مو بس لنا احنا
كعربجتمع الهويه العالميه في كل بلد بعد
تضيع
[موسيقى]
حاليا الفن ما عاد فيه مراه ورجل الحين
صار الفن هو الفكر هذا الفكر تحمله مراه
او بيحمل الرجل متى ما هذه المراه حملت
هذا الفكر المنير راح تقدر يصير لها دور
ولها تاثير واعمالها راح تعطي نتيجه
للمتلقي وتقدر تقول رايها من خلال لونها
من خلال خطها من خلال المساحات اللي قاعد
تشتغل عليها
دور كبير انه هي تنقل ما تريد ان تقول او
تعمل من خلال العمل الفني
[موسيقى]
وانا الفن عطاني مساحه
انه اشتغل بعلاقاتي على
شلون اشتغل على الواني يعني صار عندي
سرعه بتواصل
اللون خلاني لما اشتغل على اللون وشلون
انه في مساحات تكون صعبه وتنحل من خلال
لون ثاني حتى في حياتي صارت انه اه ممكن
تنحي هالمشكله ما انحلت بهالشكل ممكن تنحل
بشكل ثاني
[موسيقى]